[Music]
people often ask me what I think the
limitations are for transformative
technology and I would say that I don't
think anything replaces sitting down one
on one on one with someone that you love
or care about like there's nothing that
replaces that but we don't live in a in
a only one thing world I really believe
in having a suite of tools that we use
and so when you can't be one-on-one with
your loved one and you are forced to be
a distance then to have things that
support you in that and in terms of
other limitations i thinka limitations
are really our imagination because it's
out of our imaginations that we develop
products you know it isn't really a
coincidence that the first flip phones
look like the communicators on Star Trek
like that's not a coincidence it was
sort of set and then we worked to make
it so and so I think with transformative
technology or any technology really it's
being of the mindset that there won't be
one way and there shouldn't be one input
so we should always prioritize real live
interactions with other people we should
prioritize having healthy spaces and
cities where people can connect and
collide we should have spaces where
people of different backgrounds and
socio-economic levels come together so
we don't have stratified experiences
because part of growing up is and
becoming an adult is being exposed to a
lot of different things so we should
have those two and then we should also
have technology that helps us work on
the things that we're working on there's
one device that I particularly love I'm
really interested in
behavior change I'm really interested in
behavior change because it's it's really
quite hard and there's been a couple of
studies that have come out on human
willpower and and our willpower actually
isn't that strong and so there's two
products that work on behavior change
that I've been tracking one uses
affirmation and the other one uses
cessation as a tool so the cessation one
is called Pavlik and it shocks you when
you do something that you don't want to
do so it's a slight electrical shock but
it shocks you nonetheless in you can
sort of amp it up if you want to right
now you there are some things that it
can tell that you're doing so you can
put in a list of websites so if you have
a facebook addiction and you want to get
off fat every time you go to Facebook
the wearable which you wear on your
wrist can shock you or they've been
helping people with porn addictions
because there's basically like 10 words
that matter you can put all of those in
the app and every time you go to a
website with those words in it then you
get shocked and they're actually really
helpful because if that's a problem for
you it's a real problem and so people
need to have things that help them
change the behaviors that they want to
the flip side of that is another device
called moti which I just I just love it
it's this little ball that sits on your
desk and it's got a little face on it
and every time you do something that you
want to do you touch it and it sort of
it blinks and vibrates and it kuz and it
sounds like a really silly thing you're
like why would you do that but it turns
out that our are you know our inner mind
our monkey mind the the lizard brain
loves that yeah we just love it and so
every time you do something that you
want to do every time you go to bed
early or you don't or you get up and go
in exercise you touch it it can track
your you tell it what you're tracking
and so you can accumulate rewards for
your positive change but you get this
sort of physical sound reinforcement
that oh that was good and in both cases
they're finding that they're helping
people change behaviors that people
thought they couldn't change and so
that's a really great example of yes
there are limitations to technologies of
any kind but there's also so many great
ways it can help people with private and
personal goals that they have
[Music]